Cannes est à l'isolement dans quelques
minutes il s'élancera sur les blocs et
la règle est claire le grimpeur ne doit
pas voir ce que font ces concurrents en
attendant le tour en jaucée chauffe 9
ans de pratique une cinquième place en
Coupe de France chez les jeunes mais
avant chaque compétition là j'ai un peu
de stress parce que
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait tous
les jours et
c'est quand même une étape importante
dans l'escalade les régionales le
championnat régional d'escalade sur bloc
l'avant dernier étape pour se qualifier
au championnat de France pour cette
finale organisée dans une salle de
Saint-Avertin 30 participants dans 6
catégories différentes mais pour tous la
même règle 4 minutes pour chacun des
trois blocs
stratégique et c'est de prévoir un petit
peu à l'avance ils ont eu avant ça deux
minutes de lecture pour essayer
d'anticiper un petit peu ce qu'ils vont
faire dans les blocs l'idée c'est
vraiment de trouver la bonne séquence de
mouvement pour parvenir jusqu'à la fin
il y a vraiment cette dimension
technique qui va rentrer
Yann lui engloutit les prises et les
blocs les uns après les autres dès le
premier passage
un sans faute qui lui permet de
décrocher haut la main son ticket pour
le championnat interréal très content de
ce résultat est-ce que dans cette
compétition j'ai réussi à m'exprimer et
c'était vraiment mon style du coup je
suis très content de cette finale et
puis
tout le monde a joué le jeu dans un a
triché donc c'était vraiment une très
bonne finale un enthousiasme à l'image
d'un sport en plein essor en
Indre-et-Loire l'escalade est passé de
600 à 800 adhérents deux ans